So, ich brauche mal zum Intro ein bisschen Musik zum Wachwerden.
Könnte ich dann immer Game gedudelt haben im Hintergrund.
Leider ist die meiste ordentliche Musik M mosskatoz,
aber das nicht, weil es auch ein Game Soundtrack ist.
Das ist der Metal Hellsinger Soundtrack.
Wenn wir alle wach sind, kann ich euch erzählen, was wir heute machen.
Wir schauen uns die neue°C-Sharp 12 Preview Version an.
Die myself, durch einisses und eine 3 Features.
Ne, wir gucken uns erst mal vor.
死
….
Es ist fertig, glaube ich.
Ne, noch nicht ganz.
Hat Twitch Soundtrack oder was heißt der in den Lieblingssongs nicht?
Ich habe keine Ahnung was Twitch Soundtrack ist.
Soundtrack by Twitch.
Okay, wie funktioniert das?
How does he sound?
Twitch Soundtrack ist wieder tot?
Ich glaube, ich muss im VOD etwas anderes laufen lassen als im Stream.
Oder das VOD.
Ich glaube, ich muss etwas anderes laufen lassen als im Stream.
Okay, verstehe, verstehe.
Okay, das kann man nicht on-the-fly machen, da muss man den Stream neu starten.
Ja
Okay, erst mal updaten, erst mal updaten, archi, wie, gibt keine updates, was da los, warum nicht?
was da los warum nicht?
Ich dachte arch, arch linux hat den greif umgezogen
den krempel umgezogen
Was ist was ist force update? ach kann man das immer nicht merken, gibt keine updates was da los
Mirror noch nicht gesüngt also bei mir oder ach so mein mirror ist doch nicht gesüngt ja wahrscheinlich
ich
Da mache ich mal eine neue mirror list danke für den zapp
Fесте tv
Wie das hier no xD
Keine ahnung was ich hab
Germany
Auf was hast du umgestellt max
Und ich, weiß gar nicht, mal wie das geht mit der mirrorlist da
da gab es doch so was wo man die mirrors pingen konnte und dann die
Und und dann die schnellsten irgendwie nehmen
dann
sie
Ranke mirros das ging Lag das ging noch Mittlerweile Irgendwie einfacher
Hatte ich Mal
Also
Ich werde einfach was du drinnen stehen hast sind fertig, dann treibst es auch ein man runde update ja also leute
Wir gucken uns heute kurz gucken ob die lautstärke jetzt okay, is ja die passt
Wir gucken uns heute ein paar styles die schabel features an ich habe mir İn doin einen blog post gefunden
Microsoft der ist zwar schon vom 11. April
Es gibt noch einen neuen zur comin bastion
Die müssten wir wicked bei der gelegenheit gerade mal installieren
Genau nut你说 da욷net version runterladen wir können auch gerade mal rider und das ganze. Ob es. Musst haben wir jetzt gestartet
Ein paketёлene nicht standen ver cannons ruhig kannst ruhig wieder zugehen hier wieder zuRC allem alles gut geht zu
mensch
musst du da fünf mal zu!]
So Update check for update
Updates
Leider ich meine es gibt ja so ein paar helfer libraries davon es gibt da zum beispiel
dass schon ganz dass ganz nice ist aber
Das war auch sehr unglücklich formattiert den kram hier
Aber immer was offizielles wäre schon wäre schon sehr sehr praktisch ja
Refleck was ist denn das
Reflektor
Alles klar chat
Chatge
Weißt инд, muss wahrscheinlich als root machen oder
Ok achSo jetzt habe ich hier noch mehr was du ist , die ich gar nicht haben will
Ach das printen nur, ach so
Welcher mirror ist bei dir ganz oben
icarilla der signal
was ich trag den jetzt einfach mal ein bei mir in die mirrorlist
Und dann
Und dann zück ich einfach neu
ein
mal madina so ewig gebraucht zum speichern
Okay pack man
Jetzt Gibt's updates downgrading what
So ganz aktuell scheint, Er auch nicht zu sein oder
Naja
Okay
Komm tulast
deadline жизיים nicht neu
待 manual 6.0.2 informative so wie moment ich muss pack man selbst updateen jetzt vorher oder was weg mär familie
aber das ist das ist nicht das aktuelle
das ist 6 0 26
da alec arch bei de way was ist das ist es es da hätte someone das problem
counts
ok keine ahnung was der verschmerzen hat ich radi retained und ein paar tage bis
die mir aus ges щоnzet und dann ist gut
ok also was was soll man machen wir sind dank der mittleren käksin
sehr schön
ja eh gut es gibt ja noch gar nix neues
kann man das einfach so eingeben will doch das einfach so eingeben
nee
For users
of the now deprecate R pratique
This is required as we have moved
Ich meine, wir können auch noch Mal das Laufen lassen
Reflektor
Jetzt haben wir die MiRos List
ETC Pack «Man»
Was ist hier drinnen?
ok das ist die, was ich installiere
Ich fast 것을 brochen wer weis, vielleicht bräuchte man diese
Packel-Liste
Jetzt wird die Karte einfach gelöscht, nueh expresses
derrichardneumann.de
Alles klar
ja ja
ich hab keine ahnung
É ist es nicht
ah?
ah nee das ist nur Bail.
..
ok keine ahnung
was er für schmerzen hat aber
meine mirrores sind noch nicht
zu sehen
aber wenn ich den bei mir eintrage
dann ist er der meinungen ich soll downcrate
und erfind- wie kann das sein dass wir
den gleichen mirror haben, aber er bei mir das packman nicht findet, das neuere
packman
hä?
D.N.S.?
Das das unterschiedlich auflöst
Also das ist schon komisch
Achja gut
Okay Leute was ich mache jetzt gar nichts,
ich move meine Kegge-List wieder da hin
Kann man das überhaupt so machen?
Wahrscheinlich habe ich jetzt irgendwelche Datei-Rechte geschrottet damit
Аrate
Warum also ich wie gesagt keine ahnung warum das nicht funktioniert
Das mal warten bis die alle bis die ganzen mehr ausgesunken sind
Keine ahnung, das für der verschmerzen hat blended
Comment also нейtim
Neues
Von beige ist es nicht
Jacticamente extra syrvers lassen wir den laufend ok. Also gucken mase mal die eigentlichen sacher ich habe jetzt alles geupdatet
Was ist mit meiner toolbox los
Die ist die ist
이야기
Mal rumspinnen ok. Weiter updatedcare vormen goal dan upgraded
Das aktuelle 1972 soll also auch installiert glaube ich das ging ja eben durch
Ok ich gute noch mal man Dinner weiß ja nie was sache ist
implies das ganze bahn
Also weil ich habe gelesen es gibt drei neue features in derune preview version und die finde ich eigentlich alle
rechts
auch wartet mal
Ich muss mal kurz meine katze medizin verabreichen
Ihr könnt euch jetzt ascii aquarium angucken
Und den esen peto Hintergrund vom r pourraadores ich bin in zwei drei minuten, da
Ich muss auch noch mal kurz meine katze medizin verabreichen
Okay.
So
Das Klima al Birth versch bins auch noch jetzt ganz schön warm drin. Was haben wir denn hier gerade? Lass mal kurz gucken
Aufgerundet. Aye,簡 Ah! 24,5, ist das richtig!
Nicht ganz, ganz schön warm
Gibt es das Ascii-Quarium auch unter Windows? Wahrscheinlich gibt es da irgendeine Variante von die ja unter Windows. Ich meine mit WSL auf jeden fall
So also rubbing mushroom
Restore
Was hat die Daiqqa'z?
Die ist ja schon 13 oder so jetzt, glaube so in 12.13 ist die jetzt. Die hat
Schilddrüsen
Überfunktion, glaub so rum ist es, Schilddrüsen überfunktion
Und jetzt muss ich, der so einen Tropfen geben die die glücklicherweise haltwegs
gescheit dringt
Für die Schilddrüse und dabei muss ich mir selbst immer was langerbeliges anziehen σε fine
dass ich nichts abkriege davon, weil das irgendwie zu Hautausschlag führt
wenigstens heißt Call, Sinnvolle Sache
Ja, für die niere kriegste morgens immer was, das funktioniert aber für die niere kriegste morgens immer so flüssigkeit einmal ins depth gemacht
das checkte zum glück. Nicht. Dass da was drin ist
und das frωzte auch
ja also Leute neue C sharp 12 features wir machen mal writer aus da kann, ich würde schon
Mal revenue abstellen auf das neue auf das neule dot.net framework
also, es gibt neue C sharp features und es gibt eigentlich hauptsächlich drei neue C sharp Features
Die finde ich eigentlich alle drei ganz interessant aber ich muss sagen
ich bin ein wenig skeptisch ob's das gebraucht hat
zumindest zumindest zwei der drei features bin ich ein bisschen skeptisch ob das so ob das so sinnvoll ist weil
so gerne ich C Sharp als programmiersprache habe die letzten paar versionen hat Microsoft
coole sachen gemacht aber auch sachen wo ich mir gedacht habe hey
nur weil man dann eins zwei zeilen sparen kann muss man nicht irgendwelche doppel Yao
doppeldeutigkeiten und so was einbauen und und
mehrere wege was zu machen und ja also diese ganze geschichte auch diese da gebaut mit
records class records
struct records
fa
structs
records was nicht alles gibt da blickt keine mehr so genau durch der hätte man sich ein bisschen schöneres überlegen müssen oder ansonsten
wenn man sich so die letzte features anguckt
Diese teilweise eingebaut wurden auch neue funktionen internet denkt man sich halt so
zwangsläufig das hat microsoft selbst gebraucht ansonsten außerhalb davon hat es eigentlich relativ relativ wenig sinnen
So, es kommen zwei neue features ist die scharp jetzt blazing lie fast. Interestingly ist die scharp einfach immer relativ fast
Aber halt natürlich nicht blazing lie fast weil written in rust. Ja, das Santa find ich zum bizim spiel auch ganz gut
die
Das denen das required keyworth hat im endeffekt gefehlt schon
seit sie
dieses inline initializer zeug eingeführt haben
das hätte von anfang an dabei sein muss das auf jeden fall eine der besseren sachen dies eingeführt haben
Es gibt jetzt es gibt jetzt neue features says erst was wir uns antwortet gibt drei. Drei größere. Neue feature das erste sind primary
Constructors dafür habe ich mir tatsächlich vor dem stream leute
vorbereitung habe ich für ein beispiel überlegt was für uns zusammen im stream angucken kann wo man das besser. Sieht was ist was macht
es gibt primary, constructors da kann man jetzt zum beispiel
Ihr werdet es gleich nirgends ich zeige es euch gleich alles ist eines
da kamen konstruktor laut burst kann man ein paar zeilen coach barn da das ist das ist eines. Der features wo ich sage würde
ich weiß echt nicht ob es das gebraucht hätte
Also man kann auch einen guten mittelweg, zwinden zwischen schreibt jeden scheiß doppelt und dreifach hin wie in go zum beispiel
dass das. Das ja alles hundertprozentig explizit hingeschrieben wird oder
C++ magic, so ein, so ein, zwischen, äh, zwischending find ich ja durchaus in ordnung
Und ich finde scherb hat bis an den mittelweg ganz gut gefunden, primary constructors sind mir ein bisschen zu viel
zu viel magic, die
zwar potenziell die sachen ein bisschen lesbarer machen können aber überhaupt nicht klar ist was passiert und warum es noch ein weg für constructors um definieren
Raucht, verstehe ich auch nicht so ganz
Ja
also da bin ich skeptisch ob ich zu geil finde hier. Das nächste feature, was sie eingeführt haben ist
using alias types for any type selectier' ich euch auch das ist relativ easy
das ist quasi ein bisschen sowas wie typedef aus c++ und c
da kann man jetzt zum beispiel sagen
man möchte eine list of int
um benennen zu keine ahnung und list z完 kann das dann benutzen anstatt den eigentlichen typ ja gut
sicherlich auch nur beschränkt sinnvoll aber wenn man es braucht bestimmt ganz nice
Ob es wirklich braucht auch skeptisch aber das geht noch in ordnung und das
Letzte feature das ist tatsächlich ein wirklich gutes feature das hätte es schon lange
Gebraucht gerade wenn microsoft jetzt anfängt mit minimale api's und sonst was man kann jetzt
default values für
feelings about ich hab auch mixed feelings über die primary constructors
Naja
also ups
Wir bauen jetzt mal was auf die die alt die altmodische art ist albo ist halt modisch auf die auf die sächerp 11
variant. Wir machen jetzt mal
Ich hab mich schon im vorfeld was überlegt das bl Leben 00 dann hier
Genau, wir machen jetzt mal hier publik klasse
chatter
oder
suicidal
und
ich kann auch noch ein chat user hat einen
Username und hat ein
bull
ist Prem's ab so
Und dann legen wir den Constructor dafür, an
Der heißt kann liquidity
Cool ist Prem's und hier drin machen wir nichts anderes wie das zuweisen. Das erscheint gleich
oder
어
там
Und dann hat das den User kriegt dann noch einen Icon
Das Icon ist ituzzert sich Araussum. Ist er псих geangelt oder nicht da
So string
Wenn habe ich auch mir dann 백
Einer sternchen steher lieb und wir machen das besser als besser, da
Wenn apply
Ja ich weiß was wir machen wenn er wenn er Primes ab ist
Dann hatte ein 좋을 icon davor und wenn er halt kein Rome ist dann hat er keine ahnung
sondern
Party party phase moti
Ist ja nur zum Beispiel ich道 część wirklich jetzt für irgendwas verwenden und dann gibt es hier drinnen auch public
comment void print
eine message so aus sicht des users
String message und das passiert eigentlich, bloß folgendes drinne console Rideline
der name
Und dahinter kommt dann das icon und dahinter kommt dann die message
Redest, wenn ich das wenn ich das jetzt anlegETS Hollika war
chatter, gleich
nehmen wir namen an, wen haben wir denn hier zum beispiel
mal hier zuletzt hier, komm easy, easy lite
Und der ist kein primes sub deswegen ist falls, und wenn man das jetzt wenn man das jetzt
Message kacke hat er geschrieben und das stelle ich ihm jetzt einfach mal jetzt fühlen wir das mal aus
und
dann, bauen wir das um auf
statement 12 und da wird man sehen man kann das schon ein, bisschen kürzer machen aber ist das das wirklich wert
...schauen
Funktioniert wir könnten jetzt auch mehrere user anlegen oder nehmen wir mal hier
Den Sirius Max der ist sogar Modg you noch zusätzlich
Der ist auf Prime Sub, und wenn man denen was ausfüllen lassen soll, dann hat er
Das Geld e gloss Thursday ultra content
Also also könnte man das in den Soup 12 machen man muss jetzt sagen es ist ein, bisschen
Ist das writer nee das ist das normale pas auch stimmt es kann es dann. Singing noch
Keine da keine seeschap 11 12 unterstützung
Mal gucken mal gucken ist das nicht
Also das ist ja relativ relativ überschaubar ich meinen wir haben eine. Klasse
Da gibt das public properties drehende namen und is primes ab
Das die klasse kann man initialisieren mit dem userает. Name und ob es primes ab ist oder nicht
Aus dem
Aus dem ob er ob jemand primes ab ist oder nicht, wird ein eiken ausgewählt und wenn man hier eine message outside gibt
Da gibt es aus also das ist tatsächlich
relativ e. Say was es jetzt gibt in 11 12 ich guck mal ob ich das. Hier umgestellt bekomme falls. Das. Mode überhaupt überhaupt kann
так Breakdown
Eat
ja war doch vor stellt man das jetzt nochmal um projektweise
Tuols
Warte mal tulles shouting
toolset ja
Ja
ンフ
Okay
Jetzt muss ich nochmal neu laden weil das sonst nicht gecheckt habe dass die frame framework version gesad morphe
Ok so und jetzt schalten wir hier mal und auf dotnet 8
Und sich
Natürlich funktioniert der alte code immer noch aber
Ach so jetzt muss ich auch dotnet
Das verwendet, dass das funktioniert
Funktioniert, ok
So und jetzt gibt es ein neues feature und zwar kann man diese ganzen sachen jetzt etwas kürzer schreiben
Weil irgendjemand bei microsoft hat gedacht ok
das ist ein bisschen zu viel boilerplate code für, so eine einfache klasse die ja im prinzip nur
Ja nur zuweisung und paar datenfelder enthält. Son Microsoft hat jetzt gedacht ok
Warum sollte man diesen expliziten konstrukte schreiben? Müssen, der ja nichts anderes macht wie hier irgendwelche werte zuweisen
Und warum sollte man überhaupt hier irgendwelche properties definieren? Müssen wenn man sie public gar nicht braucht
Sondern nur intern verwendet hier so zum beispiel in dieser in dieser print metode und hier zum
zum
auswählen des eichens das haben sie sich ja gut gedacht aber ich finde ein bisschen
Es hat eigentlich nicht gebraucht weil man kann jetzt folgendes machen
man kann jetzt
Anstatt den constructor hier zu schreiben kann man den constructor jetzt da schreiben den löschen
Da habe ich auch richtig gemacht
Ich glaube Ryder kann Glass, Cannot Have Primary Konstruktion warum nicht
Why not
Das ist doch bestimmt irgendwas
Ja geht auch
Es folgt Ryder kriegt es einfach noch nicht auf die Reihe
Es geht auch
Ok es funktioniert aber Ryder mag nicht so und jetzt ist es so man kann wie gesagt man kann又
Nee ich habe nicht auf die Preview geupgradet das wird sein also man kann den
man Kann den Konstrukte Ja wir Können Tatsächlich die
Coolbox
Wie macht man das überhaupt
Ah
Alter was mit meiner Toolbox
Wildes update
Okay thieves installiert trotzdem aber das machen wir mal kurz drei dazu und vielleicht checkt sein an die neue version
Okay, es ist wohl nur diese eine install klopf gewesen nicht die anderen install knöpfe
...
Wie geht das dann mit super constructor calls ich glaube gar nicht dazu musste wieder eine inline definieren in drinnen
X sollte
langsam in Rente geschickt werden ich glaube das liegt eher an den grafikkarten sachen nicht nicht so sehr an X
Außer x kann ich in Rente geschickt werden weil Wayland nicht richtig funktioniert
Wow
Mein auge und was ist das für eine font rendering java alter
Jetzt
Das ist eines der Big Features für C-Sharp 12, ja tatsächlich. Welches, welches Doppelpunkt
Da kommt true raus, weil structs juckt nicht die Referenz, sondern structs juckt die
Werte die drin stehen. Und hier sind die Werte bei beiden gleich. Deswegen hat man früher in C-Sharp
sowas gesagt wie, Klassen sind Reference Types und Stcts sind Value Types.odypes war so das,
was es von Anfang an in C-Sharp seit Version 1 gab. Make ja auch Sinn,
gerade wenn du Low Level Sachen hast wo du wissen willst wie das im Speicher drin
steht, oder für Interop mit irgendwelchen Extend Library sind Structs eine super Geschichte.
Bei so einem Struct weißt du ok, das fängt da an. Keine Ahnung, 4 bytes
für einen Int oder sowas und dann ist gut. Also das hat beides ja schon seinen Sinn,
aber das ist nun mal der grundsätzliche Unterschied zwischen Structs Und Klassen.
So! jetzt bauen wir das ganze Mal wieder zurück.
Hier kommt jetzt ja mit Klassen, kommt Falls raus...we
hatten ja gesagt es ist nicht die gleiche Referenz.
Und jetzt ändern wir mal eine Sache an dieser Klasse und machen daraus...
records. Machen daraus ein Records.
So und hier jetzt haben wir anstatt Clash Records und wenn ich das jetzt
ausführe dann ist es true. Und das ist quasi so eine so eine so
eine hybrid Geschichte. Unter der haube ist ein Record implizit eine Klasse deswegen kann
ich auch Record Clash hinschreiben. Aber man sieht ja schon Rider sagt man muss Clash nicht
hinschreiben. Und zwar ist ein Record eigentlich auch nur eine Klasse wo manche Sachen überschrieben
wurden dass sie sich mehr verhalten wie ein Struct. Da kannst du zum Beispiel wenn du
weiterhin diese diese pointless-reference-Karakteristik
von der Klasse benutzen willst. Ohne das Hin und her kopieren von einem Struct aber
trotzdem ist dir mehr um die Werte geht in der Klasse anstatt um die Referenz selbst
diese drei Sachen gibt es jetzt in die Scharpezeit eine ganze Weile. Das hier ist Reihenwerte
basiert und wird immer kopiert, auch wenn du es als Parameter immer übergibst. Das
hier ist immer Pointer Magic referenzbasiert wo die Werte nicht so wirklich interessieren
und das hier ist eine Klasse was sich ein bisschen mit acts als Struct verhält aber
eigentlich noch Klasse ist. So Record für was verändert du sowas?
Also wenn Struct verwende man eindeutig zum Beispiel wenn ich mit
irgendwelchen doch bis hierhin finde ich ganz sinnvoll was Microsoft
gemacht hat ja. Also Struts sind eine super
Geschichte wenn du interagieren willst mit irgendwelchen C-LIBRARIES oder
irgendwelchen Sachen wo du das Speicher layout irgendwie durch steigen musst.
Ihr Anlass bei einem St profoundly EZ. Wenn ich hier ein supervision anlegende
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau also da hast du Struts normalerweise für verwendet.
So na mal rückgängig.
Klassen verwendest du eher für Sachen mit Logik drinne also wenn jetzt
nicht einfach nur reine Reine Daten Kapsel
ê Dinger sind sondern auch noch irgendwie
Logik drinne ist wenn du da verschiedene Methoden Drinne hast
Ist Prime Sub quickly
Connoagarya Bosongσ
zum Daten Zusammenfassen gewesen sind
und nachdem das so oft vorgekommen ist und
dich bei so einer Klasse ja auch eher interessiert ob die Werte übereinstimmen und nicht so sehr ob die Referenz übereinstimmt
tämä Microsoft irgendwann auf die Idee
so vor Keiner Ahnung
2-3 C-Sharp Versionen so lang gibt's das noch gar nicht
Rekords einzuführen was im Endeffekt eine Klasse ist, allerdings sich ein bisschen wie instructor hält
So verwendet man die unterschiedlichen paar dinger die Baute von unterschiedlichen Typen diese eingebaut haben
oder der Typen sind sie ja gar nicht unterschiedliche
meinungs sneakers
Das Никlas ravas microsoft das total
Es sind überhaupt Geb душ ab migrantenölzeit die haben sie haben das noch viel mehr verkompliziert z.b kam an jetzt
Wie gesagt ich habe. Ihr gesagt Rekord sind eigentlich Klassen jetzt gibt es auch noch einen Rekord lust
so gibt es auch noch. Ein Rekord
nie benutzten die Nutzung ich habe jetzt aber vergessen wie ich darauf gekommen bin
glaube ich glaube das Microsoft ist halt ein bisschen übertreibt,
mit und durchsichtigen Sachen. diese Sachen jetzt wir auch alle ein bisschen unterschiedlich
sind ja, Rekord so zu initialisieren ging schon immer, ne Klaas so zu initialisieren geht jetzt
ein bisschen Platz spart so doppelte Sachen vermeidet, ja, ihr seht ja den
Unterschied also es ist schon eine ganze Ecke kürzer also das hier entspricht auf beiden Seiten
das gleiche, was es macht. Warum hast du den in C sharp geschrieben? Weil die einfachste Programmiersprache
ist, ganz einfach man hätte das durchaus auch in anderen Sprachen machen können wobei wie gesagt
Interop mit C ist in C sharp tatsächlich ganz ok gelöst also da kriegt man keine
Anfälle wie beispielsweise in GO. Das kann man ganz gut verwenden und sie drehen ja da auch die
ganze Zeit ein bisschen dran zum Beispiel gibt es jetzt ja library import anstatt dll import was
ist mit GO also zu den fallen ich eben angesprochen habe. ist die
zusammenarbeit mit C library aus GO raus absoluter pains champ also sowohl
sieht zum beispiel so aus dass ihr meine musst zur geben. das sieht, das sieht schon sehr
sehr C-style aus. ist das aber nicht, das ist C sharp und man kann also man kann
hier wie man sieht relativ easy in C sharp mit c funktion interagieren
man kann sogar so abgedrehte sachen machen wie pointer auf den pointer und
das geht ganz gut. wenn man externe externe c library funktionen aufrufen will kann man
diese definition. also ich nichts abgedrehe dass das stimmtcrire oben wird's teilweise
schon ein bisschen eklig二
hätte du das nicht auch in bash machen können. potentiell kannst du alles irgendwie in jeder
sprache machen. gut aus bash c funktionen aufrufen ist nicht da müsstest du selbst
für solche sachen ist das natürlich ganz nice. ich muss euch sagen ich bin da eigentlich bisher
immer ohne ausgekommen aber ich gedde das. ist ok und om wird es wahrscheinlich auch an
der einen oder anderen stelle benutzen. gerade wenn du vielleicht Sachen hast,
die doppel deutlich heißen kann das schön sein. also das ist jetzt auch ein neues feature.
das würde ich auch so irgendwie unterschreiben, dass ist eine sinnvolle sache ist das so einzubauen.
hier machen sie das mit irgendwelchen tuppels,
was jetzt nicht funktioniert. ok,
ich habe keine Ahnung warum das angeblich jetzt je darum nicht funktioniert.
ah, funktioniert doch,Rider checkt es bloß nicht.
rainfall checkt es noch nicht, ja also das geht jetzt, da können ich jetzt quasi so
so ein tuppel hier referenz. wobei man sich da halt fragen muss, wenn ich sowas hier anlege,
warum mache ich nicht gleich den record, der sich measurement nennt und stringding hat.
wird ja auch in dem fall gehen,
deswegen habe ich gedacht, ich machs mal mit einem beispiel von der liste,
weil sowas wie ne liste mit einem festen typ anlegen,
das kann man so nicht ohne weiteres schnell mit einem eigenen typ anlegen.
und das hier, das hätte schon lange gebraucht
so
und zwar war es bisher so
wir legen jetzt mal, wir legen jetzt mal eine anonyme, ne anonyme funktion an
da machen wir jetzt mal irgendwie sowas hier
ich mach den, ich mach den kram ja mal wieder raus
message
so und ähmm
ja jetzt fun- jetzt funktionierts nicht
und was bisher nicht ging ist
hier die faultwerte anlegen
in der anonyme funktion
und das geht jetzt
und das ist äußerst nice
ich mein in dem fall ist es natürlich
bescheuert
weil ich könnte auch einfach sagen
public
ähmm void
keine Ahnung hier print
ähh string message
und eine richtig echte funktion anlegen
die da auch irgendwie heißt so. ja
also das wäre auch schon in ordnung an
anstatt so was anzulegen
aber sowas kann man zum beispiel auch
als parameter verwenden
oder aber
wo ich das
wo ich das häufig das problem
hatte ist wenn du kommando zeilen anwendung machst
zum beispiel
was ich ganz gerne als kommando zeilen framework
verwende ist das da
kann man kann man sowas hier machen
ich zeig euch das mal schnell
wo ist mein nougat
der heisst anders
es heisst wirklich cocoona
oder so ähnlich
was man damit machen kann
ist zum beispiel ganz
easy kommando zeilen anwendung erstellen
also wenn ich sowas hier ausführe
dotnet run minus helLAUGH
und sagt er mir
ah guckt mal
es gibt
zwei optionen die du angeben kannst
nämlich name
und name ist vom typ string
du musst es jetzt so aufrufen
minus minus name
also das funktioniert
ziemlich gut
ich schreibs mal
und das hier ist
차
ein lambda Along
achso
das ist natürlich
okay, wobei warum nicht
..und jetzt kann man da default values angeben
das ist enorm nützlich
für frameworks in der richtung
wenn man die quasi anonymous function lambda aufrufe joins an der stelle verwendet
oder
für minimale api ist das auch sehr sinnig
weil die haben sich doch aus
die haben sich doch
wir machen mal eine web-anwendung
wartet mal
ajem
Kekkel
..äh
..dot.net
..new
web
das ist es glaube ich
so mahmme
..machmal die
die
das andere projekt auf
allah was
autor
kekkel
trust
jawoll
wir trusten
äh
..was
ehh ok
es ist
es ist die RID3R preview version
die noch irgendwie so mahmme schmerzen hat
ah
eh
wo once
unload
load
jetzt vielleicht
ok
target framework C sharp 8
äh
schon dabei ihre Minimal APIs zu pushen
als wenn ich das ding jetzt
hier jetzt starte
then starten in web server
und wenn ich sag
dann kommt der hello world zurück
so
das ist relativ easy
ter zu bauen
ohne das du
dich mit
udc
us Ocean
wobei
obwohl
hat
vrage zeichen
ja
damit, dass es default parametern gibt
ich kann jetzt sagen
und bedruckt
ist dwell
und wenn ich jetzt
und wenn ich jetzt nichts übergebe
dann geht es nicht kaputt
sondern nehmt den defaultvalue
also das ist wirklich eine äußerst sinnvolle
funktion dass es es jetzt hier erlaubt
ist
das ist quasi das Gegenstück zu
also es gibt ja
es gibt da schon
default values für paramet' da gibt es da schon
ewig
seit 15 Jahren oder So
In harmonica war allerdings bisher immer nur
echten funktionen vorneihalten also
wenn ich sowas machen wollte hier wollte
void print
dann konnte ich hier zum Beispiel sagen
string message gleich
eat chat
das geht schon
ewig
ich glaube nicht immer
aber schon ewig geht das in z-shop
aber hier in anonymous-funktion gegen das die ganze zeit nicht
und das ist ein sehr sehr sinnvolles feature dass es das endlich eingebaut
haben
gab es in zwei Punkten sowas wie einPeople-Objekt
was
du meinst was? wo von allen Klassen ab stammen oder wie oder was?
Ja das gibt's
die stammen alle von Objekts ab
außer außer und solche Sachen die stammt
von Value-Type glaub ich ab der wiederum von Objekt
abstand
also details mit denen beschäftigt man sich selber
Er meinst sowas wie gleich-Default
Ja, ja, das gibt's das gibt's auch
Gleich-Default gibt's gibt's auch
Definitiv ist halt immer
ist Hz schwierig zu erklären
Immer der
Ja wenn ich sage, er default wert ist blöd
Der default wert für. Einen typ und das ist das ist bij
Reference-Types ist das immer null
Deswegen sagt mir auch hier ich muss sagen dass das in alle bild sein soll
Ja bei struct sieht das zumواh school schon wieder ein bisschen anders aus
Ja, gibt das gibt es gibt es tatsächlich
das ist nicht das gleiche ja
Dass das hier wäre das gleiche
Wobei man an manchen stellen null nicht verwenden kann die fold aber schon
Aber
wie gesagt also die fall wird der in funktionen gibt schon ewig
aber in anonymen funktionen jetzt erst sei es die schaft 12 und das ist sehr nice dass das endlich drinne ist
Das erspart ein viel rum getrickste wenn man es einfach direkt. Benutzen kann
der
Also für mich ist das eindeutig das beste feature
Was die mir schrès 12 bringen den rest könnten, so eigentlich behalten aber das ist wirklich wichtig das hätte schon lange gebraucht
tangled
weißt du, was sie weirdes machen, dass das die
Stange
Star
phm mit laure vielleicht noch irgendwo
Aber ich muss sagen asb net ist sehr angenehm
es ist ja ja auch auch
quasi voll stack
das welt set kann frontend rennen
und backend sachen ausführen
du kannst mitねكن zb seiten schon vor rennen beim ersten mal ausliefern
überallodo
er sei ich auch so
das besten ist in der regel das womit man sich am besten auskennt
tatsächlich sehe ich auch so sie ich ganz genauso
aber spt etwa finde ich persönlich sehr angenehm
so das waren jetzt erst mal die 90 scharp features es gibt allerdings noch ein paar neue funktionen
what's new in dotnet 8 und da sind jetzt zur abwechslung ein paar sachen darin, wo ich
denke, ja das ist sehr nice. zumindest ein paar sachen davon, da zeige ich euch jetzt
auch noch mal welche also gerade die neuen random-funktion finde ich, finde ich sehr
joymax was ist mit der frage von personal können sie linux gemeint, da musste ich
die mal fragen. definiere können ich bezweifel dass die personaler überhaupt wissen wovon
sie sprechen themen sagen ich habe 15 jahre erfahrung mit linux in dem ande nbereich wenn
du sie hast, keine ahnung, die wissen wahrscheinlich selbst nich, ich würde sagen
ok weiß gar nicht wofür man das braucht, ich muss euch sagen ich bin ja der old school ich verwende
immer noch jason.net ich weiß nicht wie ist bei euch aussieht chat
wenn einer von euch hauptsächlich csharp benutzt benutzt ihr noch jason.net?
oder seid ihr ja schon komplett beim build in?
jason serialisieren
ich weiß nicht also wenn ich jetzt super kras mega performance bräuchte dann
würde ich vielleicht was anderes nehmen aber in der regelREICH mit
jason.net eigentlich immer noch am angenehmsten bis letztes auf das build in
umgestiegen okay
moin kingflex
to
ja also was ich jetzt viel interessanter finde ist also das interessiert mich
jetzt auch nicht so sehr sie haben irgendwas an irgendwelchen time stead
darum gedreht das wird ja fast so abgetreten von javascript mittlerweile
aber was ich ganz cool finde ist hier ist das hier.
und das ist sowas, das fehlt mir schon lange das kann man übrigens relativ
Easy sich sich bauen aber sie haben jetzt endlich mal ein paar sinnvolle methoden dafür
eingebaut dass man arrays zum beispiel random
Durch mischen kann und so was
Man siehts hier zum beispiel
Können wir mal ausprobieren
Also es gibt jetzt get items
und shuffle
Und damit kann man zum beispiel in random item nehmen wir das mal von hier
gucken wir, dass einfach hier copy copypasten kann
ich mach mal, ich mach mal grad wieder das andere auf
wartet mal
open
consoleapp
this window
consoleapp 2
Jawoll
Hör schonmal den Klampel
Ja
hatten, Albeddel
und jetzt machen wir int
Mal gucken, ob das mit einer stinknormanen Liste geht
var list gleich new list
int
So
Schreiben wir jetzt mal etwas rein
1 5 8 3 2 4
so 45 ja perfekt
So und da kann man jetzt sagen
Ähm
ja
novo
kann man sagen
random shared get items
und jetzt hier eine Liste übergeben
ok das funktioniert nicht warum
weil
The type argument cannot be inferred from usage
ok
geht das mit listen nicht
ok als array funktioniert es
haben listen ich eh schon schaffe
ja gut
ja meinsch
ääh, neley haben sie nich
ich will die auch vielleicht nicht shuffeln
sondern ein random item daraus daraus holen
also was das hier macht ist folgendes
das holt sich random zwei elemente
aus der liste raus
und das ist was das finde ich sehr nice
das das mittlerweile drinne ist
beste variation benamung aller zeiten
hallo
wenn schon nennen wir das jetzt I
run
ran
oh zack 3 und 2 hast du rausgeholt
ja wunderbar
3 und 45 er herausgeholt
2 und 2
er rausgeholt
kann auch doppelt
kann auch doppelt kommen
also das finde ich sehr praktisch
dass das jetzt eingebaut ist
get a random item
aus
ner liste
bzw. aus dem array
das ist praktisch
konnte man sich früher relativ einfach auch selbst zusammenbauen
aber es ist schön dass es jetzt
schön dass es drinne ist
das gleiche gibt es noch hier mit shuffle
Wobei man das dann wirklich als span braucht. Da kann man zumindest jetzt auch
Listen irgendwie mischen lassen damit
Also das finde ich gut dass das standardmäßig was eingebaut ist
Achja noch noch ein hinweis nerves warum warum die hier谎那么
random sch hat verwenden dass ist auch
relativ neu
nicht super neu
Also das gibt gibt es schon. Ein paar versionen früher war das ein problem ich zeige euch
Was das problem früher gewesen ist mit random übrigens ich glaube dass problem
existiert in der form gar nicht mehr deswegen kann ich euch nur. Zeigen was was das problem war ohne dass hier ist wirklich
Seht warum warum will. Ihr eigentlich, mein auto complete gerade nicht
ville
Aber was hat, er für probleme mit meinem auto complete gibt sich mehr auto computation
gibt's nicht gibt, kein gibt, kein auto komplett, mehr
und
Wannec
Nö
Ok, meine autokeける Internet kaputt. Es macht nicht. Na gut also ich zeige ich zeige euch was das eigentlich ver joue
Gleich Null I kleiner K保空
So
Früher das problem gewesen ist wie gesagt ich glaube ich glaube das Problem an sich existiert gar nicht mehr
leute früher bisschen
Wenn sie nicht aufgepasst haben blödsinn gebaut wenn sie random zahlen generiert halb economieren wollten
Ja
Und die haben so was gemacht hier war random gleich nu random
Und dann wurde gesagt random. Next. Ja ne random nummer zwischen zwischen keine ahnung zwischen 50 und 5000 so
Und haben sie das ausgeführt haben sie gewundert warum die zahlen immer doppelt sind wie gesagt ich glaubt das problem ja genau das problem
gibt es gibt es gar nicht mehr
aber das war ein problem früher weil
Früher random geseadet wurde mit denen
mit der uhrzeit auf jeden fall
Das problem ist hacker aren maintenance
Also da gab sicherlich auch ein problem ob das stress Apa nicht aber das war ursprünglich genau das hier war das problem
Wenn dupapern nummer gemacht hast das wurde immer mit der urzeit geseadet
und wenn du jetzt schleifen hattest die super mega schnell waren
Dann
Da war bei mehreren durchlauf durchläufen die urzeit die gleiche und
Und das random hat den gleichen sieht bekommen und die gleiche Zahl ausgesputzt. Ich glaube das gibt es in der form jetzt nicht mehr
Vielleicht ist es auch nur zu langsam wegen dem console drijt leihen
kann auch sein Aber
Zumindest ist das ist das ein problem
Problem gewesen bei random früher
Wir können sie mal ausprobieren
Aber ist
Nie
So viel schneller also zwischenέ
Mein auto comedy gibt's nicht mehr hier vor in nuess
Schaue wir mal ob das jetzt irgendwie
Also das problem ist wohl wirklich gefixt mit random aber das war früher ein problem definitiv wenn man da wenn man danach sucht
ja w STM random number loop man, Donnern
Bis ihn die hat ein Cumライon mit
und
Wie man das lösen konnte war eigentlich relativ einfach
Man musste das random eben außerhalb von der schleife packen dann wurde das hier initial gesiedelt
Und hier immer die nächste nächste random. Zahl aus dem generator genommen
Also das war relativ easy zu fixen, aber da hat sich microsoft. Gedacht.idez was
Warum eigentlich so kompliziert
Lass uns doch einfach so was einbauen wie random punkt cheart punkt nächst
und
Dann hat man die ganzen probleme nicht
Das ist jetzt, ein
Was red safer initial gesiedelte random der keine probleme macht
Und ich glaube sogar das ist fill nicht mit logs geregelt sondern irgendwie
Anders also das ist wohl auch sehr
high high performance ja hier diese diese random geschichte
Und
Es gibt auch noch nicht so, lang aber ist eine äußerst sinnvolle
neue
Variante gewesen diese da eingebaut haben
Naja und anscheinend gibt es jetzt in der neuen version
Get items
Get items und shuffle für race noch
Finde ich beides auch sinnig
Zufallszahlen bei algorithms sind immer so eine sage für sich warum das funktioniert seit
langer zeit, du darfst halt bloß nicht darauf spekulieren dass das jetzt irgendwie was
vergleichbares ist mitusterfahre von atomen oder so was, was wirklich do还有
bit du kannst du kannst einen zahlen generator mit dem gleichen spukt immer die gleiche
aber cheeky
sein sogar
Die gleiche
Reinfolge aus aber das ist ja oftmals auch gewollt weil das ist halt einfach 2006
Und wenn du, sachen reproduziell haben willst ganz sagen wie man beispielsweise der gleiche sieht in minecraft
Ist das ja auch sinnvoll
Er kommt alles wie immer auf den anwendungszweck an
Für. Spiele oder sowas ist den echter zufallhalten generator komplett unsinnig weil viel zu langsam
Gut mittlerweile gibt es gibt es in vielen cpu. S資len unterstützen
Mit mit fragt mich nicht, wie das funktioniert
rauschen von irgendwelchen signalen auf
Keine. Ahnung es gibt ja mittlerweile schon etwas bessere random generator sich einen in aktuellen in aktueller hardware drinnen die
mehr random sind
Aber ich glaube da wenn du irgendwie ein spiel hast was was wirklich
So high performance random generator brauchz beispielsweise du hast sowas wie pass of exile
Und lässt es also du bist der anbieter von pass of exile und hast dein random generator auf dem server
journée
so
Also das ist eines der neuerungen hier in sich habe die ich wirklich gut finde dass sie endlich zwei sachen eingebaut haben in random
Nämlich random times aus einem array und in array durchmischen wo man sich denkt warum gab es das nicht schon seit 20 jahren
Ja aber gibt es nicht ja es gibt noch ein paar es gibt noch ein paar neue abgedrehte sachen es gibt so es gibt
Sec Zhong
Wie sehr nische würde ich sagen hier
Mions braucht also quasi
so was wie
Gilbert einmal angelegt wird und dann nur noch raus gelesen wird nie wieder geschrieben wird und dafür halt ein bisschen
mehr dangersoptimiert
Muss ich halt auch erst mal lohnen
asty
Da gibt es noch ein paar mehr
Magic
für cpu interne funktionen also
irgendwelche
Vektor matrix
Multiplikation
auf der cpu
Nicht multithreaded sondern
Wie nennen sich das?
Diese, geschichte das ist ja nicht
sind oder sowas
Das ist ja nicht wirklich multithreaded das. Ist ja quasi multi instruction also in einer
instruction mehrere inputs multipliziert und sowas, ganz abgedrehter Shit, das reference jetzt für dass man es ordentlich verwenden kann
Wenn, du eine cpu hast ist unterstützt
Er wird aber auch langsam eckelig mit programmieren. Ja hier simpt sie veut einig
Kannst, jetzt avx 512 benutzen
Ja gut data validation ist abfuckt das was im framework drin ist blutzt keine mehr
Man kann das finde ich eine ganz coole sache
Den garbage collector irgendwie nach gucken lassen wie viel memory auf dem system jetzt verfügbar sind für irgendwelche clouds
Für, irgendwelche cloud szinarien so nach dem motto man hat cloud ressourcen die hoch und runterskalieren
Und der garbage collector hat vorher nicht mitbekommen
wenn beispielsweise ressourcen
beschnitten wurden und jetzt kriege das mite kann man irgendwie so ganz
Obskur art und weise refreshen lassen was wie viel memory. Im system ist
Also meinen gehen sie auch eine schönere abspur. Überlegen können als irgendwas interne ist was mal über reflection aufrufen
Aufrufen musste schon, echt bisschen bisschen. Trinch
somsp growth generator gibt
reflection
improvements, native eot support das haben wir. Schon. Mal in. Zwei drei streams
Komplett uns angeguckt
Und ja das funktioniert viel besser noch als in den letzten dotnet version. Es ist immer noch nicht, ganz un Niye
Wie go wird es wahrscheinlich auch heran weil einer ist der ursprünglichen
ursprünglichen mit design entscheidungen bei go war er wurde von. Anfang an mit drauf ausgelegt
Dass man, go apps
singel single binary kompilieren kann rückwärts kompatibel bis zu linux kernel 2 6 32 oder so
Ganz so geil ist die. Neue kompiliere technik in dotnet 8 nicht
Aber sie ist schon deutlich besser als noch bei. Dotnet 6 und, dotnet. Sieben
ja wir haben auch schon eine
Anwendungen damit gebaut und dass das funktioniert wirklich ganz gut
Er muss nur schauen auf welchem. Zielsystem bzw für, welche ziel system und auf welchem system man das ganze kompiliert sodass
Ist möglichst lange rück DYLL aufwähcH in es
Die können, eh noch änderungen machen weil es ist ja
Ja noch preview
ja
Ja per performance improvements gibt neue, docker images
Aber ganz ehrlich in groß und ganz. MALE STARS also die die random funktion und halt hier die
diese 390 sharp version wir sind allerdings erst bei preview 4
Da kann vielleicht noch das ein oder andere reinkommen
weil dort, nicht 8 beziehungsweise ahí sch unaware 12 dass er blueberries
Das kommt wahrscheinlich erst wieder im oktober oder november raus
Immer weiß ich gar nicht. Hair Geschehen was fest Talknah November
Ja
Also rademit denke Ich. Ja denke, dass wir das wird. Vielleicht noch so ein paar. Kleinigkeiten stableennommen
Mal, Hand
Was New in dort net coA 8 es heißt nicht dort net Co8 google heißt nur noch dort net 8
Weil microsoft gerne leute verwirrt mit derbenahmung
1 xbox 1 x
ich
Warum war das random官ic static was meinte
Das gab es. Gab dieses random Schert früher einfach nicht du musstest dass immer selbst anlegen
wenn du das außerhalb von der schleife angelegt wir es auch kein problem aber
Viele haben ja damals den fehler immer gemacht
Um einen NIU random innerhalb von der schleife gemacht und hat es halt mehrfach den gleichen sieht gekriegt und verhalt auch langsamer
Und du hast die gleichen werte das war halt nie sondern ich
gut mittlerweile haben sie sehr eh gefixt
Krass oder dass die xbox world auch schon zehn jahre her ist
Denkst du es macht sin zum lernen von sich ab best kript umzuschreiben oder kleine moiter
ja also best kript die umzuschreiben
wahrscheinlich nicht best kbelievable daseinsberichtigungen für kleine sachen gerade wenn
ו
wir gibt es da keine gescheitermonatsübersicht mensch
also heute habe ich sogar zwei maorn heute morgen und heute abend donners dach linux server davor
ein bisschen geschwätze abends right guck mal hier beispielsweise kaum die woche dafür aber
auch irgendwie sonntags zweimal also es ist es ist wirklich random hauptsächlich tatsächlich
eher abends außer am wochenende da ist es komplett random aber ansonsten eher abends ja ist schwer
zu sagen immer immer dann wenn es mir danach ist und ich zeit hab und bock hab und ich zu müde bin
wir haben uns die neuen features angeguckt und ich habe die features eingeteilt in hätte ich
nicht gebraucht ist ganz okay und hätte es schon immer geben sollen
ja das gibt es aber das wird jetzt heißt eine lange nicht dass ich es machen würde
ja dann mache halt PowerShell aber ganz im ernst da würde ich da würde ich lieber meine
meine dort netd commando sign tools mit der neuen ahead-of-time compilgation zu
single binaries bauen und auf die server verteilen bevor ich mir PowerShell auf
allen linux server installiere und dann irgendwie auf meine dann noch eine dot
net runtime brauche und dann auf meine c sharp d family aus PowerShell
zugreifen nicht ne das würde ich nicht machen
äh
f sharp ist für die funktionalen fifehats
das ist auch normal also komplexe sachen den bash machen ist übelst der
abfrack so für so für sachen die maximal sagen
wenn wir mal so ein zwei seiten lang sind terminal seiten lang sind ist das eigentlich alles
ganz in ordnung aber danach wird es danach wird's ekel filter also bech
ist halt ist halt immer noch immer noch gut zu können ja fürs so zum beispiel für
irgendwelche bill scripts oder sowas ja zum beispiel für sowas hier bild punkt Ephan
was also nicht mal großartig was macht außer docker-container starten und
lacked ins binäanderâm
jahr für so was ist betsch halt sehr ihre isse aber ansonsten wenn's wenn's
bisschen komplexer wird und wo spätestens schluss ist mit best es
wenn's ums thema multithreading geht und so was ja du kannst in best
theoretisch halt auch verschiedene prozesse machen entam ende warten
und so was aber das wird schon sehr eklig also spätestens da ist halt mit best vorbei
ja wie gesagt also meine zwei minuten breakdown ist
primary constructorsanting nicht gebraucht finde ich eigentlich auch keine gute
entwicklung dass man mehrere varianten für die gleichen sachen
bei immer mehr feature sind sie scharp einbaut doch also man kann jetzt bei
ich habe es gar nicht mehr
mal kurz gucken ob ich alles rückgängig machen kann
na gut dann moment
history
Aha
debatet
da sind wir
So
ich habe es rückgängig gemacht
Also man kann jetzt ich zeige es dir mal zum vergleich
also, wenn du eine klasse angelegt hast früher in C-Sharp
dann musstest du das so machen
Tu legst eine klasse an
hat ein property mit name
hat ein property, hat ein property ist primes
So die haben jetzt eine neue feature ausgedacht
und zwar ist das hier
dass der brauman übrigens nicht da oben
ist das hier quasi das gleiche wie hier
Und so dass man jetzt den constructor nicht mehr hier inline schreiben kann
dass man den constructor nicht mehr inline schreiben muss
sondern hier oben an die klasse anschreiben kann
so als primary default constructor
da kann man sich den ganzen anderen kram sparen
sieht auf den ersten blick ganz nice aus
weil es dann noch schön kurz ist
aber magic und was ich halt nicht mag ist
dass es zwei drei wege gibt das gleiche zu machen
das finde ich doof
also das ist ein feature das hätte ich nicht gebraucht
type aliasing ist ganz cool
das ist sowas wie type def
so ein bisschen was wie type def aus c jetzt auch in c-sharp
du kannst quasi zum beispiel wenn du immer
liste von int anlegst
kannst du jetzt quasi einen eigenen typ definieren der intlist heißt
und dann macht er das immer
ja und default values für lumber expressions
ist relativ selbst erklärend
man kann jetzt bei anonymous funktionen auch
die faultwerte angeben falls parameter
nicht gesetzt sind
also
hätte ich nicht gebraucht finde ich auch nicht sehntvoll
kann man benutzen ist okay und das hätte ich schon ewig geben müssen
das sind meine zwei minuten breakdown
falls du überhaupt noch da bist
ah doch ja nice
und dann haben wir uns jetzt ein paar framework funktionen angeguckt
und da gibt es also das erwähnenswerte
absolut auch von dir
erwähnenswerte sind tatsächlich neue funktionen
für random nämlich dass man jetzt random items aus einem
arre picken lassen kann oder ein arre random isen lassen kann
in mt standards library ok
konnte man vorher relativ einfach selbst bauen aber warum
selbstfahren wenn man es auch im framework dabei haben kann
Sowie im soul
ist es eine idee ob es mit view auch sowas wie react native ja
gibt es es gibt äh wir is das bei view
ach moment react native sorry
ich hab mich vertan ich dachte du meinst sowas wie next oder nookst
wie heißt das bei view
ja aber es gibt ich weiß nicht wie es heißt ja es gibt auch sowas wie fiery
act native für für view habe ich schon hab mich schon gesehen auf github das
ist irgendwie ein framework das unterstützt noch mehr als nur viewed
kannst auch damit an react machen oder oder
glaube sogar dass welt geht auch
ja also das funktioniert auf jeden fall ich kann ja allerdings nicht sagen wie es
genau heißt was ich hab nie verwendet habe
oder fliegt über meinen urlaub mal ein praktikum in einem betrieb zu machen ja
das warum im urlaubt du musst für deine ausbildung in praktikum machen
da ich bisher auch nie was praktisch umgesetzt habe die erfahr mit praktikanten
also ja du kannst natürlich praktikum machen aber du musst doch in ein
praktikum in einer ausbildung machen oder dass die überhaupt abschließen kannst also deine
umschulung die umschulung geht auch nur wenn man am ende in praktikum macht von irgendwie
in einem halben oder 3 vierteljahr macht auch lieber in den praktikumsplatz dafür klar
natürlich sicherlich nicht verkehrt sich vielleicht trotzdem also 2 3 wochen was anzugucken
und dann mit denen auch gleich was auszumachen wie sieht es aus mit einem praktikum wenn du
dein praktikum an auch wirklich machen muss aber ist auch so oder also du musst du musst
doch auch für die umschulungen im praktikum machen soweit ich weiß
dass musste das musste schon bisschen unterscheiden wenn du einen
umschulungspraktikant für die drei vierteljahre kriegste kannst du schon
als alsカンタ betrachten ist es ja im endeffekt auch macht ihr auch gerade
eine ausbildung hat die ausbildung für euch vielleicht nicht angefangen aber das will ich
von drei zwei drei viertel meistens er
und ich weiß dass ich viele schwer tun einen praktikums platz zu finden was ich irgendwie
auch verstehen kann weil betriebe sagen halt auch warum soll ich warum soll ich in
elf monate da in den umschüler hinsetzen wenn ich mir einfach an
adsubia einstellen kann denn komplett quasi ausbilden kann so wie
Das für. Richtig halte und ich dann mit dem am endeffekt auch was anfangen kann. Der.Anderen seite ganz ehrlich
die sollen aber alle auch gar nicht so wählericht als meine persönliche meinung jetzt ja die sollen aber alle nicht so nicht so wählerich
sein weil
alle suchen sie nach fachkräften aber keiner möchte dann auch mal sowas wie
In umschulungspraktikum von elfen monaten eben anbieten was sich ja irgendwie bei es du kannst nicht sagen ich will fachkräfte haben aber dich selbst an der
ausbildung
oder den umschulen von fachkräften nicht beteiligen das ist halt Shake
Das beißt sich irgendwie kann es nicht welche haben wollen aber nicht dafür sorgen dass es welche gibt
Also dass sollen sich certaines nicht so anstellen soll. Das machen sollen das ruhig machen
50 pro stunde
Es überhaupt gibt es drei euro 50 die stunde jemand arbeiten zu lassen
Dafür kann es ja nicht mal hin und zurück zur Arbeit fahren
Ja dann müssen sie sich, dann müssten sie sich nicht wundern, wenn sie keine bekommen
Fachkräftemangel ist eh gelungen du meinst gelogen wahrscheinlich vermut ich jetzt mal wenn ich das so lese
fachkräftemangel ist gelogen
ja und nein, also
Fachkräftemangel in dem sinne
Jeder der eine ausschreibung macht hier ich suche ein x y it Experten wie auch immer
dass der einen bekommt ja das ist nicht mehr so
also aus der sicht ist es schon ein mangel, weil nicht jeder der sagt ich hätte gerne einen auch jemand bekommt
Auf der anderen seite mangel in Form von wenn die sich mühe geben und eine gute
gute kondition bieten was gehalt angeht was home office angeht was
Ja, dass unsere sulla tercer reality of life. Geschichten angeht das ist eben in guteninki
Die bekommen auch welche also
das ja aus der einen sicht stimmt und ne aus der anderen sicht stimmt auch wieder nett
Ja deswegen, das denke ich auch, deswegen sollten sich da vielleicht mal ein paar mehr betriebe zusammen reißen, auch mal elf monate
um schulpratvoll um schuller um schulungspraktikum. Ermöglichen
Ja, dann sind sie. Selber schuld
Ja so kann man es auch sehen es gibt zu wenige um alle stellen zu besetzen jahre aus dem gesichtspunkt ist es. Ein. Mangel
Und tja wenn sich dann auch vieler auch noch so blöd anstellen kriegen halt noch mehr niemand
Ja ist leider selten
Wobei ich jetzt schon immer öfters gesehen hab in letzter Zeit dass zumindest mal
Gehaltsspanne so ungefähr drin steht
Es sei denn es geht euch so wie sei mein Ehemaligenarbeitskollege
Ehemaligenarbeitskollege
das hab ich ja schon erzählt deswegen nur noch mal ganz kurz, Recycle Story. gezahlte
den haben sie ja richtig verarscht!
der hat sich beworben
als Senior DevOps probably engineer oder lief als sowas
und die haben imDonald shortly gesagt
Gehaltsspanne 95.000 bis 100.000
ST are cool nice
Hat sich beworben hat, mit, denen, auch Vorstellungsgespräche gemacht hat mit denen. Sogar so eine hat, wie heißt das so einen so einen
Übungsübungen
Gespräch gemacht. So wie würden sie jetzt reagieren wenn eine Meldung über Systemausfall
Rein kommt und so was in der richtung und am Endeffekt wenn er, fertig war mit diesen ganzen mit Vorstellungsgesprächen mit
Übungs sachen hat ein paar Wochen gedauert hat sie über paar Wochen hingezogen
und
Danach hat er gesagt ja gut und wie war es so und was was sagt ihr und alle waren sich einig
Ja also er würde das gerne machen und die wollen ihn auch haben und im endeffekt als es dann um den vertrag ging
haben die gesagt
Budget das budget hat leider doch keine senior stelle mehr hergegeben, wir können ihn jetzgang 75k im jahr bieten
Und dann hat er halt einfach gesagt
Und süß
Er hat, es auch instant abgelehnt
Verarschen kann ich mich, selbst alle ihr könnt
Mich eine stelle ausschreiben von 95 bis 105, dann machst du den bewerbungsprozess
Durch bist dir einig und dann sagen sie auch nie gibt nur 75
Obwohl vorher immer
von ner anderen gehalts spanne geredet wurde, da hat er auch gesagt ihr könnt mich mal also
Ich weiß gar nicht was denken die sich. Denn eigentlich
Was was denken die sich ich, meint geht die ernsthaft davon aus
dass irgendjemand sagt ach ja
Mir hats aber, so gut gefallen, bei euch
20k weniger ist auch, okay
Also andere was denken die sich, vor allem was ist denn das für. En start
was für nen start, ist denn das schonmal, du wirst noch verarscht bevor du überhaupt unterschrieben hast
Normalerweise wirst du erst verarscht nachdem du unterschrieben warst
Keil ahndung, die sind echt komplett lost gewesen, dass die niemand finden, wundert mich nicht
T.Rex
Das ist blödsinn du kannst gar nicht alles wissen
Und wenn die halt nur jemand wollen
mit einer ganz speziellen Kenntnis, dann ist das ihr Ding das finden sie halt nothing
Ja es ist also bei manchen sachen, ist es sicherlich sinnvoll
Aber alle Sachen ist es auch wichtig, dass du jemand hast, der ahndung hat von
Ich sache mal ahndung von technik ja ahndung von it themen hat
und grob genug bescheid weiß um sich schnell einarbeiten zu können das ist bottom bei den meisten sachen eigentlich sogar wichtiger
Als jemand der so eine ganz spezielle fachkenntnis hat aber wenn sie es haben will sollen es halt sollen es halt
suchen und nicht finden
orial
Ja mache das ist das beste was du machen kannst ich habe es auch gemerkt job gewechselt insit mehr geld
Atter auch
Ge mauvais
Wir limitation
Burger King
Birdie
die
K Due washes
Des
collaborative
dasのは
weary
Das belongs
Da müsste ich mir wirklich was was realistisches aus den fingern Sauer ich kann jetzt
ja nicht komplett
Sie tauschen auf auf auf kunuu, weil ich meine ich war immerhin über zehn. Jahre, da. Kann, er nicht
alles scheiße gewesen sein. Man sitten sie dem jahre, da geblieben
ich muss sicher sagen dass ich muss. Als schon. Sagen dass die
realität
Und die wunschvorstellungen da recht weit auseinanderging
Also die die, eigen wahrnehmung
oder, so die eigene ein bildung wie toll man. Ist
Hat sich nicht so. Sehr mit der realität gedeckt
In allen themen würde ich jetzt mal nicht. So unterschreiben
Aber ich sage, mal so du kannst dich
In einem breiten spektrum relativ schnell einarbeiten wenn du halt ein, bisschen ahnung von den von den. Themengebieten
An sich. Hast ja also wenn du beispielsweise relativ viel
edgeers-cloud geschichten gemacht dass kommt auch relativ schnell in google und aws reihen umgedreht
nicht nur
wenn, du
bischen bisschen ahnung von
Keine ahnung wenn du ahnung hast von um bund dies jahren kommt auch gut in red hat und und sonstige sachen rein
Ja das ist das ist schon kein ding es gibt allerdings ist gibt allerdings sicherlich
spezialfälle wo das nicht so ist ich ich würde mal sagen. So sape und konsorten magiser andere sein
Wobei ich da glücklicherweise bisher einen großen bohren drum gemacht habe und auch weiterhin
Machen werde
Genau, so wie ich um windows bisher großen bogen gemacht habe und das werde ich auch weiterhin
Bei, mir im vorstellungsgespräch haben sie mich gefragt
Herr max dass das war so ein apUnaler trick trick personaller frage irgendwie
haben sie mich gefragt
was müssten wir machen dass sie so richtig ärgert, habe ich darauf geantwortet windows administrieren
War eine ehrlich antwort ja, das würde mich ärgern. Und das würde ich auch nicht lange machen
Weil wir sind die archmirror jetzt aktuell ok, soll ich noch mal gucken
Hey, die archmirror sind aktuell
Yes
Windows als Anwendungen hier desktop betriebssystem zu benutzen oder Server darauf zu betreiben sind doch zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar schuhe
Chat. Ich kannst doch nicht vergleichen
Ich würde im Leben keine Windows Server betreuen wollen
Ich meine 5 Windows schon scheiße genug jetzt weil auf dem desktop hier
Vielleicht
Vielleicht ist das vielleicht ist das wirklich der Hintergrund Aber ganz im ernst
Wenn dass es echt der Hintergrund sein sollte dann würde ich Ja noch weniger dort arbeiten wollen
Also wenn du schon Beschissen Wirst bevor du unterschrieben hast es irgendwas verkehrt
aber
Bei mir bei mir ist das mit einarbeiten ähnlich
Also ich denke auch dass es bestimmt eine halbes Jahr oder Drei viertel Jahr oder erst Nächstes Jahr wird ... bis ich dort
Wirklich so weit den Durchblick hab dass wenn ich mal morgens alleine da bin was kaputt geht
Ich, dass komplett alleine fixen kann seien es war super simples ja
das dauert ne weile wenn ich genug den Durchblick hab
ja also Fahrtkostenerstattung sollte schon seien
gerade wenn es ein bisschen weiter weg ist, Du kannst nicht von jemanden erwarten dass der
dahin fährt und vielleicht irgendwie noch, keine Ahnung, mit Hin- und Rückfahrt 70- 80 Euro
Zugticket kosten ausgeben mittlerweile gibt es Deutschland Ticket aus gibt für
irgendwie so ne zu random sache wir haben jetzt doch kein Bock mehr
also ganz ehrlich Fahrtkostenerstattung sollte es eigentlich immer geben automatisch
Aber es ist nicht so
Im Oppo
Schonmal Fedora Server nie
Weiss gar nicht ob irgendjemand Fedora als Server Betriebssystem benutzt
Desktop ja aber ich bin kein fan Sakie von Fedora und auch lustigerweise von
und ich wüsste nicht was ich groß vermissen würde unter Ubuntu
Mein alter Arbeitgeber weiß ich nicht ob die so was gemacht haben aber ich wüsst ihnen zutrauen
Lpa an Linux und dann hast du DNS Auflösungsprobleme
aber Lpa an linux ist schon okay, wenn es besonders kleine Container Images sein müssen
Lpa an linux ist schon okay, wenn es besonders kleine Container Images sein müssen